منوره سياسيه يجريها الرئيس الامريكي بين
كيافو وارسو قبل عودته الى واشنطن تتزامن
مع الذكرى الاولى لبدء الحرب الروسيه ضد
اوكرانيا زيارات تترافق مع اجراء القوات
الامريكيه مناورات عسكريه مشتركه على
الجانب الاخر من اوروبا
بمحاذاه الجزء الغربي من روسيا اي في
فنلندا تحديدا المناورات في منطقه لابلاند
الفنلنديه يشارك فيها ما يقرب من الف جندي
امريكي وتحاكي حربا في القطب الشمالي
المناورات ستستمر حتى السابع عشر من مارس
المقبل اما التدريبات فتقسم الى نصفين
تدريبات شامله مكثفه شمالي فنلندا وتمرين
الفايكنج المشترك في النرويج الجيش
الامريكي حدد هدف التدريبات باظهار
الاستعداد لدعم الشريك الفنلندي من خلال
نشر قوه قتاليه ذات مصداقيه في الجناح
الشمالي لحلف الناتو وسينضم الى التدريبات
في النرويج اكثر من عشره الاف جن دي من
بريطانيا والدنمارك والمانيا وهولندا
والنرويج
[موسيقى]